Nick Carter welcomes his first son ET  Kant exclusively confirmed that the  Backstreet Boy singer and his wife  Lauren kit welcomed their first baby  together on April 19th around 11 p.m.  his name is Odin Rane Carter in German  mythology Odin is a widely revered God  earlier this month the couple tease  their son's name to ET is it something  sentimental put it this way it's a very  strong name and something like et has  learned that Lauren wasn't 30 hours of  labor she delivered the baby via an  at-home water birth  the couple couldn't stop gushing to et  over what each other would be like as  parents earlier this month what are you  guys most excited to see in each other  just this unconditional love that he can  give to his son and the son can give to  him and the family that we just always  wanted she's the reason why I I felt  comfortable because I knew that she  would be the perfect mother and she  would be able to help me teach our child  all the things that he needs to learn